I think it's a really unique city that
feels like it's got its own sense of
what it is and what can happen here
[Music]
Chicago has always been kind of an
important art place never like the
coasts just kind of its own weird thing
and I feel like something very very
special is happening it's a collage of
food it's a collage of culture it's a
collage of language it's a collage of
backgrounds and it's a collage of
conflict it's third largest city in the
country but basically ignored and
because of that you have people doing
interesting things because it's
completely self-motivated it seems to
have its own virtues of don't overstate
the things that you're good at and I
think as a result there's always been a
quiet goodness here it's kind of an
island
you know its own little cultural island
[Music]